die besucher ich habe mir erlaubt auch
letztlich unserer sehr jungen
bekanntschaft einen äußerst delikaten
rotring zu bestellen das ist ein 15
jahre alter katholischer tisch sein
wahrhaft stolze rhein mit einer
lebhaften farbe aus changierenden roten
rosen
er ist hört sich im ok und doch herzhaft
in der blume ich würde sagen
ecuadorianische schokolade
brasilianische vanille und oberpfälzer
beerenfrüchte am gaumen die perfekte
balance aus schwedischen eichenholz
tönen kubanischem tabak und einem hauch
kokosnuss aber wirklich nur einem haus
alkohol ist da mit drin oder
ja selbstverständlich gott sei dank mit
exquisite partner wir ihnen das nicht
passiert
nach dem motto kontrolliert kultiviert
exquisite partner ihre
partnervermittlung mit niveau
[Applaus]
[Musik]
im schnitt so exel
scheiß auf dieses niveau